bonsoir les titres de ce journal deux
anniversaires d'abord celui de la mort
du général de gaulle et celui du 11
novembre que nous évoquerons à
l'occasion de la mise de l'inauguration
qui aura lieu demain du nouveau monument
aux morts de preixan dans le roussillon
également des images de l'arrivée du
corps de pablo casals en catalogne à
barcelone
andré wilms air parlera de son dernier
livre depuis nous vous montrerons les
buts de la rencontre de football
montpellier béziers et vous entendrez en
avant première leur qu'istres de
montpellier est notre premier reportage
concerne donc les cérémonies
anniversaires de la mort du général de
gaulle
laurent barat